25 millones de contagios el kobe 19
continúa avanzando en eeuu
mientras se temen los efectos de la
nueva variante británica
el presidente joe biden trata de
concienciar a la población next films en
los próximos meses las máscaras y no las
vacunas son la mejor defensa que tenemos
contra el hobbit 19 james con angie
[Música]
en brasil un estudio de la universidad
de sao paulo y la ong conectas derechos
humanos afirma tras examinar más de 3000
normas federales de 2020 que bolsonaro
lidera una estrategia institucional de
propagación del virus el país tiene
cerca de 9 millones de contagios y más
de 216.000 fallecidos unos efectos que
se están notando especialmente en manaos
donde rige un confinamiento total y
escasea el oxígeno tanto es así que
venezuela está distribuyendo oxígeno a
la región amazónica tras brasil le sigue
colombia en número de casos al superar
los 2 millones de contagios ya suma más
de 50 mil muertes mientras las unidades
de cuidados intensivos del país se
encuentran en máximos argentinas pese a
liderar la vacunación de la región
también se acerca a los 2 millones de
casos y a las 50 mil muertes también es
crítica la situación en méxico que tiene
1,7 millones de casos pero alrededor de
150.000 fallecidos con récord de muertes
diarias en la última semana las
autoridades denuncian que los
cementerios están cerca del colapso
entonces en algunos casos pues si nos
hemos visto
basados por por el vamos a decirle el
segundo pico de la pandemia
américa con alrededor de 50 millones de
casos es el continente más afectado por
la pandemia una situación que no parece
que vaya a mejorar pronto con el ritmo
de vacunación aún lento